I just happened to stumble upon your
Twitter I think you tweeted if you're
planning on writing a script in 2020 and
you haven't started yet
start today make a file do a title page
write your first slug line and then your
first line of action tomorrow you can
jump right in my intention writing that
tweet and I guess I just say that I
wrote that on the 31st of December so
it's if you're planning on starting a
screenplay in 2020 start it in 2019
because when you sit down and it's just
it's just this vacuum of blankness
there's just this sort of feeling of
like oh my gosh I have so many
possibilities and I just don't know what
to choose but as soon as you get
something down regardless of what it is
I think things just really open up
because all of a sudden your
possibilities start to narrow and
there's a lot less time spent in
evaluating these possibilities as
opposed to these possibilities so
there's just an effective way to
continue moving forward because you can
always take those possibilities you can
take them later and trans them translate
them to other ones you were allowed to
rewrite so just get it going and don't
worry about facing the blank page and so
that was my advice I've just just write
something down in 2019 and it's gonna
set you up in 2020 for success insofar
as you will be writing a screenplay
don't even worry about what it is yet if
that's what you're afraid of do you
think that's what stops a lot of people
because it seems like this monumental
I'm writing a screenplay and now Oh am I
gonna take on this title as a
screenwriter is it going to be a
legitimate title just just set it up
don't don't overthink it just do it is
take some of the fear out of it to do it
this way yeah I think sitting down and
just typing something or writing
something longhand just gets you moving
and I think that movement is just a good
habit to be in and I would say that is
more
important especially for beginning
screenwriters to to learn that it
doesn't have to be great it doesn't be
perfect it doesn't have to be even what
it will eventually be it's not going to
be what it will eventually be so don't
worry about it being that just get
moving
it's like training at the gym it's like
if you want to lift 200 pounds you first
have to lift 100 pounds if you want to
lift a hundred pounds you first have to
lift 50 pound like just and not that I
can lift 200 pounds um but I'm just
saying you have to start somewhere and
that where you start is not the
destination so just start and you can go
back and figure it out later
and also - is it is it less intimidating
about wait a minute I'm not actually
gonna be writing like full sentences
sometimes yes yeah I think there's
definitely a freedom in the waist
screenplays are written that we are not
beholden to strict prose punctuation and
grammar and all that stuff you have a
fair amount of freedom there is a very
clear formatting for screenplays but
that formatting allows for I think a
tremendous amount of freedom that once
you are comfortable with I think really
allows an authorial voice to come
through was that something that was a
surprise to you that you didn't realize
like wait a minute I'm not writing an
actual novel here I don't have to make
sure that I'm completely grammatically
correct with something I can just do
sort of this cryptic how's it going yeah
yeah you know I mean just you know the
in terms of the conversation and and
yeah I remember the first screenplay I
wrote that was imperfect all the action
lines were perfect prose and I had a
table read of it and it was it was
horrible because it was the slowest read
of my life and afterwards a friend who
was participating the read couch me and
she said your story is fantastic I think
this is great this
this could be a name maker for you but
you have to you have to change every
single action line and say well oh okay
she's like yeah just it needs to be like
a screenplay and so I had this story but
I didn't have a good screenplay
and so I went back in and changed I
didn't make a single story choice
different but I has changed all the
action lines and that was the screenplay
that has gotten me more notice than any
of my other work okay was a nice friend
yeah
was this table read here in LA yeah okay
yeah I had a table read with friends in
LA that just put put together I have a
small group that meets semi regular
whenever someone has something they say
who's available and when are you
available can we get together for a read
and it's a combination of actors and
writers and so we'll give the actors the
bigger parts and kind of use the writers
to fill in some of the smaller parts and
hear it out loud and then immediately
just sort of get feedback from everyone
are they doing the feedback after the
script is read through or in the moment
after it's read through so we hear it
once completely I need you to record it
so I can hear it back
I'll also record the feedback so that I
can hear that back which is also
something I'd recommend is just being
used to recording everything because if
you have to pause to take notes every
time you're not gonna be present with
the person that you're talking to
you'll also miss things and you'll go
back later and that note you won't be
able to make sense of but you can hear
it back and you hear exactly how they
said it and now oh that's right that's
what they said so definitely record
everything that's really powerful to
hear your own work spoken by someone
else mm-hmm it's great you'll hear a
line that you go I think that line is
gonna kill it's great and then it's just
great reading but the line falls flat so
the line is bad
also you'll hear things that you know a
line that was just functional like you
needed that line to get from A to B and
it's there and you think it's not great
but then someone reads it
and it all sudden like that line pops
more than any of the others and you're
like well I don't know if that line is
necessarily great but clearly there's
something that this actress found with
this character that allows that line to
pop and figure out what that is because
there are going to be opportunities
elsewhere in the script to use whatever
that actor found in that character to
make sure that that is in every other
scene that that character is in
you